the post-millennial reports this as a
lutheran pastor in chicago offered drag
prayer time for children
aaron musser who was ordained this
summer donned a blonde wig white dress
and makeup to share in worship with the
children in his parish this is saint
luke's lutheran church of logan square
and they publicized the event on
facebook they're very proud of it
let's um
let's
take a look at some of this go ahead and
play it
so with many other exhortations
john proclaimed the good news to the
people
the gospel of the lord
you may be seated and i'd like to invite
any children or people who would like to
see
a picture book that i will be showing on
the ipad here anyone who'd like a closer
view of that to come up and sit um
um
come up and sit somewhere on the ground
here i have an awesome story to share
with you today i'm really excited
to share it with you i have a question
first of all have any of you
no
no is this so this is everybody's first
time they're ever seeing a drag queen
hello
um i am also
a boy most of the time when i'm here but
today
i
you are
today yes beautiful so
the story that i want to share with you
today is called joy
okay
no surprise there female pastors of the
church they got two female pastors and a
guy in drag and um that's what's going
on at that lutheran church
um hey and what is there to criticize
it's just a grown man playing out his
sexual fantasies at church in front of a
bunch of kids that's that's what this is
by the way i mean the drag drag and all
this kind of stuff uh
these these are men who like this is
their sexual fetish is wearing women
clothes women's clothes
um and
if that's
your thing that you do in the privacy of
your own home
it's it's really weird
but you can do that in privacy your own
home nobody's gonna know i and and i'm
quite happy not knowing
like i have no interest i'm not going
into anyone's home
performing checks to see if they're
wearing women's clothes or not i'm not
doing that so you want to be in your
home doing that
you can no one can stop you
but
you want to play that out in public it's
a different story and you want to
involve children
in your sexual fantasy well now that's
that's really a different story because
that's that's uh pedophilic that's child
sexual abuse you should go to prison for
it obviously
um
this would be a perfect time
i mean if there was anyone in that
church who was not a degenerate freak
lunatic
which of course there isn't because they
wouldn't be in that church if they if
they were
but if there was just one normal person
there this would be a great time
for
to hearken back to the gospels
and uh jesus christ overturning
the tables in the temple
because as much as we're told and for
decades now we've got this false
impression of jesus as this peacenik
hippie kind of guy who's just hanging
around all the time and uh you know
non-non-aggressive telling everyone hey
chill out man
kind of like
presenting jesus as if he's like the big
lebowski or something
as much as that is the impression we're
given that's actually not
the jesus that is portrayed in the
gospel
and that jesus was
uh
very passionate
about of course you know especially
about protecting children
protecting vulnerable
about the truth jesus is truth
and the life
um
but he but on top of that also
aggressive
at times
hostile towards
sin
hostile towards evil
and aggressive and even violent on at
least one occasion
because the turning over of the tables
in the temple was a violent act
in fact we're told in one of the stories
that he fashions a whip
it's interesting that says he fashions
it not even like he grabbed one but he
actually took a little bit of time so
there's premeditation here of of like
making this weapon
and using it against people
causing physical pain to them well we
can assume to be whipped
so this would have been a great time for
a little bit of a turning over the
tables in the temple approach
but unfortunately all the people there
are complicit and are also groomers of
children um so that's why that didn't
happen well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt well show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content